uh yeah i definitely recommend uh doing
something crazy congratulations you want
to do it you want to do it
i know i mean i want to do something
crazy yeah i mean i think we've
it's it's weird because this year has
just been a crazy crazy year just in
general we've already done some pretty
good crazy things it's not even
[Music]
i would actually be down like six seven
days yeah i guess because you you've got
you've got me to tell you all everything
they're doing yeah right i've done i've
found out how to exactly everything
exactly
yeah no but like i i mean you know if i
want to [ __ ] get because you know i
do want to get into shape um and so you
know why would i you know what what
better excuse than to do for you know a
charity or an event i don't think it's a
good way to get like
super fit there's like way better ways
to do it yeah but you just want to get a
kickstart yeah i think it's well like
you know it's just to say that you did
it as well oh yeah it's a cool [ __ ]
story to tell it's cool yeah but i feel
like it's especially if you want to get
fit you know it's i'm sure like there's
so many better there are better ways of
course there are better ways to min max
it but at the end of the day if you're
not having fun or if you're not doing
this you don't have to move the
motivation there's going to be more
efficient ways to do it yes but if you
don't want to do it you're not going to
do it you know it's kind of it's kind of
like it's it's very similar to i guess
learning a language and everything like
that is like what i've realized is that
there is always a more efficient way to
learn japanese or learn another language
but at the end of the day the most
important thing is
having fun
no no
no joke no jokes it [ __ ] is okay look
if like we've like clowned on duolingo
so much but if you if duolingo gets you
up and gets you doing a language
exercise every day that's way [ __ ]
better than other methods that are way
more efficient absolutely
yeah i mean sometimes the stars align
right and yeah everything just kind of
works out yeah and uh you
set a challenge and it kind of just hits
every box you want yeah you know like
for me it was started out as me just
wanted to do something stupid yeah and
then i was like oh i get personal
fitness i get to make some content i get
to cycle with my friends and then i get
to also raise money for a great cause
and yeah hopefully i get to entertain a
bunch of people throughout it so i think
you know you sometimes you just
you know you're like this is gonna be
tough this is not gonna be easy and it's
gonna it's gonna be a nuisance to my
life because you know like i couldn't
really do much after the day was over
yeah people would text me but i would
just i couldn't [ __ ] reply i was just
so i was too tired i wouldn't look at my
phone yeah i literally ate
changed clothes showered put stuff on
charge went to bed and woke up at six
five a.m every day yeah it was tough and
then today i had to wake up at 5am to
get the shinkansen from hakodate to get
here to film this
i literally finished it yesterday yeah
yeah it's crazy to think i was in
hokkaido yesterday yeah and you just got
the show you're in auckland this morning
yeah yeah this morning this morning oh
man yeah it's it's uh yeah and like i
the number one tip to cycling long
distances is just wake up early but i
i'm sure when chris comes on he'll tell
you all about it we had so many
arguments about what time to wake up
right we actually we like had on like
four years because yeah because chris is
like the number one like i hate waking
up in the morning post we had like a
shouting match at one point about this
in like a restaurant we were we were
this is like five we are so stressed out
right because you're cycling all day
you're pissed off yeah and and i was
getting i was getting really pissed off
for chris it was
under the bridge afterwards like but we
were like so pissed off what time did he
want to wake up
he you know because he was arguing that
like uh if i wake up too early i'm i'm
you know i won't get enough sleep and i
won't be in condition to do anything and
i'm like
just get over it
like
because just get good
don't be tired don't be tired i'm sure
you can talk about it
we've done video shoots together right
and sometimes you do shoots with a lot
of people yeah sometimes
for the for the the greater good of the
shoot you just have to sacrifice things
cool yeah and i think chris cause chris
normally controls everything on his
videos yes he controls it so that he
doesn't have to wake up early right yeah
but for this it was like we're just not
gonna hit
the places because i i i was like
insistent on the fact that
i did not want to cycle in the dark yeah
i just thought that oh it looks like
[ __ ] first it looks like [ __ ] and also
it's just unnecessarily adding like
dangerous elements to it for no reason
like
yeah you have lights on your bike but
you can't see stuff as well you can't
see the the rocks and the roads these
roads are [ __ ] yeah you can't see the
potholes you can't see the cut the cars
can't see you as well like i just i just
thought that it's you're just adding
unnecessary danger for no reason yeah
and we could just wake up an hour early
yeah you know because originally we're
waking up at like we were starting at
like 9 30. and i just thought that's way
too late yeah that's surprisingly late
and so we eventually got it down to like
8 8 30 after arguing a bunch and like ah
because i was on the other crazy
spectrum where i was like listen if i
have to get six hours of sleep five
hours of sleep for a week of my life so
be it like it's it's it's a week of my
life i'll get over it i'll recover i'll
just sleep extra yeah like obviously
it's not ideal but you just make
sacrifices to make stuff happen yes
uh but christian is like yeah for the
good content yeah but you know it was i
i understand where he was coming from i
know i'm younger and i can it's way
easier for me to i mean you're not that
much young
i don't know like
six years younger i don't know like for
me i waking up and losing a bit of like
for me five hours of sleep that's not a
big issue if it's like it's a big issue
i'm i'm saying if okay if we were doing
this and i was like you have to get five
hours of sleep and we're doing it you
wouldn't be happy about it but you'd
probably be like all right yeah okay so
like i think the difference between
being 30 is that you just know what your
body is capable of right you know you
know some days where you think okay okay
okay so yeah i'd say like i understood
where he's coming from yeah i wasn't
trying to be a dick about it i'm not
even 30 and i can already feel that
no that's that's because you're almost
30 joey
you're almost that's i think that's the
big tester where you've limit tested
your body enough to know what the limits
are right so i can do like five hours of
sleep and six thousand sleep but i know
i know if i do five to six hours of
sleep i'm gonna have a write-off day
it's there's
of equal exchange i'm going
like the price is going to catch up to
your body yeah if i have a five hour
night the next night is a 12 hour yeah
yeah exactly exactly i understand that i
that sleep was definitely a necessity
yeah um my solution was just go to bed
earlier because chris was going to bed
like midnight i was going to bed like
10. yeah because i think chris got
really unlucky a bunch of stuff i mean
he'll talk about it a bunch of stuff
piled on yeah emails and important
things he had to do so he wasn't
sleeping properly
which is also like
you know it was i i just told everyone
i'm like don't don't bother don't
don't talk to me i'm not going to reply
to anyone yes because i'm just like i
just i just don't want to worry about
anything i just want to turn off yeah i
told the agency i was like hey
just you can you can ask me do it do
what you want but i'm not gonna i'm
gonna reply unless it's like gigger
urgent yeah um so yeah i went to bed
every night like ten so waking up at six
is like oh that's nothing yeah that's
plenty yeah my mindset was we just go to
bed that's eight hours of sleep yeah
because a lot of the times we all said
bye and we're like we would all have
dinner and talk a bit then we'd all go
to bed like we'd all head off at nine
yeah so i was like just go to bed you
know yeah easy worst case you get seven
hours of sleep which is fine seven hours
of sleep is also in the recommended
amount that's still pretty good you know
yeah um so that's what i was thinking
but then obviously you know
everyone sleeps different as well yeah
is it um is it an old man thing now to
really value your sleep i value my sleep
don't get me wrong i i normally i i am
hard on the seven eight hours necessary
yeah but i i when it comes to like a an
outdoor shoot where we've all traveled
and a lot of people and money and time
has invested i'm completely of the
mindset of like if i get two hours i get
two hours that's one of those because
like i've i remember actually for for
the drifting special yeah yeah actually
there's no sleep for that like the road
trip we got like no sleep yeah we got
like a lot of yeah the road trip was
like five members like
i stayed in the hotel that we stayed in
in hakodate right and i remember i was
like oh yeah the last time i was here
we literally were there for four hours
yeah we booked a hotel room just to
sleep for four hours we got to that
hotel at i think it was like two a.m no
it was like one or two a.m
and then we had to wake up at i think 16
yeah yeah yeah yeah we literally booked
a hotel yeah for just like four hours
yeah
yeah we just did that because there was
a video shoot and we understood that
like to make these things happen we had
to sacrifice sleep exactly obviously
it's a different i understand it's
completely different when you when it
comes to the fact that i'm like okay
sacrifice sleep now exercise for eight
hours yes yes that's so i i
i i was confident we were all content
yeah
it was we were both tired it's been five
days cycling we were pissed off but it
was you know we we understood that like
immediately after you're like that's
four under the bridge yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
me and chris piss each other off all the
time
chris is just like 80 of chris is just
angry at all times anyway well you know
we're not angry
of shoots yes and i was like this is
both of our shoots so
you can't just be like this is what
we're doing yeah i'm like no i'm pushing
back hard on it
i'm gonna be the i'm gonna be the one
push his back
uh you know because i
we we were slowly getting later and
later and i was like yeah if we start at
10 we're [ __ ] yeah we're not gonna
make it because also okay so to to
preface how all this works it was eight
days and it was like 95 kilometers 90 85
85 and we were just about finishing
before sunset when we were doing 95 and
80. um because we were we were slow and
we were taking our time we were stopping
for lunch and we're doing stuff like
that
and um originally the last day was going
to be 160.
and as we were getting closer to that
day this is when i was like dude we're
gonna have to wake up at like four a.m
yeah and like i'm i just it's one day
i'm chill to do it and we were like
having arguments and stuff about it
because i'm not waking up before i am
because yeah i'm not gonna be able to do
it i was like alright fine so we
eventually came to the conclusion that
we had to like
somehow spread out the distance in the
remaining days so instead of doing like
80 100 160 we did 120 110 110 right um
and that was tough because then that
turned what was going to be two normal
days and a really hard day into like
just three hard days right right right
um which is tough that was tough
that was tough really that's hard that
was hard but you know you get used to it
i don't know it's hard but it was really
fun you sound like you know you know
when like marines go through their like
their training where they like run
[ __ ] like 100 kilometers or something
a day i think you're just like you know
you just got to learn to push past
yourself
it's weird it's like yeah when they're
like it was tough i'm like
it's not the word you would describe
that it's weird how quickly your body
can adapt to things oh of course i mean
you if you have like you you know like
we had like hard deadlines right like
you had to do this distance in the day
yeah so it's kind of like
you gotta do it i mean your body and
your mind is just incredibly flexible to
a point yeah yeah you know you you're
capable of way more than you think you
are oh yeah well i mean i mean like
remember like the the crazy schedule
that we had for like la miami and then
australia in the span of like a week and
a half like when we were looking at that
before it was happening we were like
there's no [ __ ] way we're gonna be
able to yeah
but by the end of it we were like okay
yeah that was tough but
i mean we still did it
anything can be handled i never met prep
like literally it's just all prep if you
just prep properly for this this kind of
stuff it's so easy yeah yeah definitely
you know and it's really amazing how um
fast and how many days your body will
kind of like even like by day four like
i said like hills became way easier like
i had not had any really really tough
hills before i've been doing a lot of it
on tokyo which is really flat tokyo
doesn't have that many hills um and also
like the exercise bike you can put the
resistance up but it's not the same yes
the resistance the resistance cannot
mimic going up a hill no it's just
totally different because you don't feel
like you're going to fall off
you never feel like you're going to fall
off the resistance right it's just going
to push back whereas the hill it's like
if you don't like cycle properly you
just fall off your bike yeah um and you
you know changing gear it's a whole
thing and uh you know it's it's
impressive how even after like three
days it becomes so much easier if you
just keep going yeah um and you get like
rapid improvement if you do it every day
yeah of i guess like learning like
language like anything like anything
like if you wanted to get your muscles
to be like to actually get like healthy
and grow the muscles properly then you
you take rest days yeah and i was
definitely not eating enough protein i
just don't know how i could eat that
much protein
liquid protein i truly who needs protein
when you've got carbs i've tried to eat
protein but it's hard enough to eat like
calories let alone like yeah the protein
i should have taken protein powder with
me or something
but i just i just couldn't just snort
process so much there's always so much
stuff yeah yeah i should have liked
just like powdered
yeah
it's just like you you put on all of
that and then you've got to worry about
the stream yeah it's just like another
added layer of like [ __ ] yeah so you're
like mentally tied you're physically
tired yeah
man yeah well congratulations for
actually achieving it [ __ ]
achievement right thank you crazy
looking forward to seeing chris's video
and your like edited down video as well
meanwhile i was sitting on my fat ass
playing xenoblade 3.